brought 100 people together and it's
their job to figure out which one of
them has the highest body count
everybody has a number but our sexual
histories are not just about numbers
they're intertwined with our identity
self-esteem and how we relate to each
other it's time to find the one are you
guys ready to talk body
kid so for the first round please leave
immediately if you think you have the
lowest body count in the entire row
three two
one
now it's time to discuss but you can
only talk about how you lost your
virginity I was 16 we both lost our
virginity at the same time and I thought
energy drink was romantic so I poured in
like wine glasses on vacation when I was
20 that's how I lost it okay that was I
was
22 and I feel like I was on the older
end of like what is like
societally thought I was actually a I
guess a fairly late bloomer uh when I
started having sex I was actually 22
years old and it was towards the end of
college and I had my first kiss and had
sex at the same time I I had one other
part partner uh between then and then
being like 32 years old so I went 10
years which is like two partners I was
on a show player trip in Disney World we
ended up sneaking back to like our like
Disney themed motel room okay I already
know that you're a freak school chir
trip to Disney and your mom's there said
enough said I personally don't subscribe
to the belief that your body count means
much of anything about you because I
don't think that sex necessarily needs
to mean a lot about you I feel like it's
like it's like a pythag I don't know I
feel like body count is a small part of
sex and sex is a small part of who you
are so overall for me
personally are you enjoying this new
pilot on Jubilee let us know by
subscribing to this channel now let's
get back to the video please leave the
circle if you believe you have a lower
than average body count in three 2
[Music]
one okay we have 39 people left so for
this next elimination we need to
eliminate people who believe they have
average body counts now for this round
you can only talk about your preferences
in Bez or your
kinks all right I have no pinks I'm not
going to lie okay uh I'm an ass man okay
you're an ass man
come on in come on inol was just telling
us about his love for
ass we include chains wh handcuffs
people have brought up like pegging like
a lot but I can't tell if they're joking
and if they're just trying to like I'm
fairly vanilla myself I got say also
like the term vanilla is like shifting
choking used to be like but now it's
just like okay guys yeah that's part of
my van yeah I remember the first time a
guy like tried to choke me he didn't
like warn me ahead of time and I was
like what is happening right now butt
stuff foot stuff and spit this could get
real weird guys I had a girl
accidentally key on me that was
accident I don't think kinkiness
necessarily correlates 100% though cuz
you can still have a high body count but
not the the kinkiest person I don't
believe in monogamy from Arkansas the
Bible Belt we don't talk about I'm a big
advocate for like exactly it shouldn't
be something to be ashamed of I realized
that
so if you think you have an average body
count please leave in three 2
1 in terms of speaking about like my
body count and body count as a whole I'm
probably still not really comfortable
talking about it but at the same time I
personally like am not really intimate
unless I'm in relationships so I feel
like there's a clear pattern you can
just kind of look through the Instagram
and see the relationships and pretty can
do some basic basic math there and
figure that out so all right
and then there were
fewer what up so for this round we
have to narrow it down to 10 people so
seven people have to leave for this
round to get to know each other a little
bit more you can talk about your
professions go
[Music]
ahead what do you do for um influencer
and like Social Media stuff you don't
happen to know a chick that goes by
Kazumi do you oh I know who she is but I
don't know uh I'm a theater director I
used to be in the military now I do
sales so I used to be a software
engineer no sex sex I think that's what
we're trying to
out please only remain if you believe
you're in the top 10 highest body count
in the entire room otherwise leave in
three 2
1 I think body count determines if you
feel good in your body but I think
personally for me because of trauma it
definitely helped me kind of own myself
because I am an exotic dancer the word
ho all get thrown at me all
the time and at first it worried me
because I was worried about what other
people think but as I got older I
realized that labels don't matter
because you don't really know what I've
been through you don't know me
personally and the reason why I'm doing
what I'm doing and how it makes me feel
personally all right now we're on our
final 10 people so everyone go around
and explain who they think the one is I
don't know I feel like it's a really
hard thing to look at someone and just
like assume how many people they may
have slept with um and I've only okay so
I had a conversation with Carter earlier
and he told me that he was in the
military and in my experience I know
that military men like to sleep around
Dam uh when I was 32 uh pandemic hit and
I was actually in a relationship at the
time with a woman but I came out as a
gay and I just had kind of been bottled
up for you know my entire life uh and
just like felt repressed in so many
different ways uh one of which was
sexually so that was in the span of the
last 3 years that it
was Avery did I wear my Garb
to today does anyone here know what a
fet life
is
ooh is that like oh I'm not explaining
but so I think he answered the question
for
me on first instinct I would have said
Jesse but now that Frank was talking
about fat life which I have no idea what
that is I I would have to say
probably I think it's Avery you know why
because your wig is long so that tells
me you must like it long
too um well Frank very confidently
asserted that it was him so it could be
him statistically I'm like several
standard deviations above the mean for
sure but also I was talking to Avery
about her profession and she was talking
about uh her friend Kazumi who like
popped up on my t to feed and she talks
about how she she does sex uh
professionally and like I think a lot of
it she's like very popular and like
maybe through like you guys might know
each other from work or something like
that so uh Frank or Frank or Avery um I
would guess Frank or
Laur and honestly I would put also no no
offense no offense no offense but miss
Evette I want to put you in my top three
cuz I
feel I feel just because I'm older than
everybody would have no but you're also
fun I feel like you've just I feel like
you have fun I I have fun yeah you you
see fun you're you're in my top
three max it seems like you guys all
wanted to vote for Frank do we agree
that Frank is the one
yes time to find out if Frank is the
one
if the light is green you are the one if
the light is red you're not the one good
luck
[Music]
thanks
[Applause]
[Music]
2 so Frank you are actually not the one
how do you
feel
different uh you know for people who are
like really into the Kink world you
know looks can be very
deceiving okay thanks so much
cig time to find out who the one really
is the
one is Avery Jane please step
forward
[Music]
so what do you think this game taught us
um that you can't really like look in a
room full of people and tell who's like
the or has the highest body
count or make any assumptions about
anyone's
sexuality okay
yeah so I absolutely knew coming into
today that I was the one unless one of
my co-workers workers is going to be
here and they weren't so Avery would you
be comfortable sharing your body count
so at this point I don't actually know
my exact body count I stopped keeping
track it's like definitely over a
thousand for sure yeah I do I am an
adult performer and actress okay um so I
get around a
lot thank you for sharing and thank you
guys for being here and thanks for
[Applause]
watching
[Music]
[Applause]
find me on the
[Music]
Hub